Hey David, let's talk about white privilege.
Do poor white people have the same privilege
as rich white people?
I'm going to answer the question.
It's not a hugely relevant one because the
question of privilege is better suited for
if you want to look at racial privilege, you
need to really look at it where as many other
variables as possible are held equal so that
you're really just looking at the variable
of race.
So the question of whether a rich white person
has more or less privilege than a poor white
person is a fine question to ask.
The answer is easy.
A poor white person, white person has far
less privileged than a rich white person.
I mean there there's a question that that's
your answer.
It's not a very interesting question because
it doesn't really relate to the problems we're
trying to deal with in society.
If everything other than skin color is the
same, then we can look at the specific effect
of skin color as a factor.
And when you do that, if you imagine a poor
white person and a poor black person, if the
only difference is race, then there is some
degree of white privilege that the poor white
person has over the poor black person.
And in fact there are some really interesting
studies with regard to employment where they
were for a job out jobs were open, low skilled
jobs, whatever.
I think some were housekeeping, custodial
type work, other low skilled jobs, and really
big studies were done with thousands of resumes
with identical skills.
Names were different, traditionally white
sounding names versus traditionally black
sounding names were sent out and the response
rates were tracked.
And sometimes the white sounding name with
the same credentials as the black sounding
name would get as much as a 50% higher a callback
or interview rate.
So that's an example.
We're looking at low skill jobs.
You're not talking about wealthy people or
even upper middle class or middle class people.
Um, and you see that there is a specific difference
when varying only names that imply a certain
race.
Okay, that's interesting to look at.
Poor white versus rich white.
Of course wealth confers privilege and wealth
confers advantage.
Now I think it's also important to talk about
the reality that at a certain level of wealth,
wealth can start to override the lack of privilege
that might come from some other factor like
race or nationality or religion or gender
or whatever.
Right?
There would be a certain point at which one
is so wealthy that regardless of their race,
they are going to have a privilege in society
that will mostly make up for a characteristic
that would typically confer a disadvantage.
Um, so the question is, is a fine one, if
you are sort of getting at the privilege that
wealth confers, but from the point of view
of thinking about OK, um, poor white people
and poor black people might live in different
neighborhoods, one of those neighborhoods
might be better connected with public transit.
That would be a form of privilege that would
relate to race, that would not necessarily
be, uh, obviously visible unless you really
try to fine tune and equate all but one variable,
isolate one variable and try to figure out
the differences there.
That's my thought.
A white privilege is different based on wealth,
but it's not a particularly interesting question.
Since we know, particularly in this country,
wealth confers a ton of privilege.
If I've misunderstood your question or you
disagree with my answer, by all means, let
me know.
We've got a great bonus show planned for you
today.
The bonus show is
for members and patron members and patrons.
Become a member@joiningpackanddotcomorbecomeapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.